public sénat
bonjour et bienvenue dans europe hebdo
au parlement européen à bruxelles
l'enquète de cette émission s'intéresse
aux effets du bisphénol a sur la santé
reportage entre paris et bruxelles avec
des citoyens des chercheurs et des
industriels
mais tout de suite l'actualité avec une
question centrale quel avenir pour
l'europe l'europe sera t-elle plus
fédérale c'est ce qui se joue
actuellement avec peut-être une union
des banques européennes face à la crise
les européens ont trouvé la martingale
ils vont faire l'union bancaire les
risques seront désormais partagée par
tous les dépôts des épargnants garantis
par un fonds européens et la
surveillance des banques renforcer sous
le contrôle strict du 35ème étage de la
tour de frankfort où siège lé auguste
président de la banque centrale
européenne plus de défaillances de
faillites en série ni de déséquilibres
monétaires grâce à plus de prévention de
précaution de supervision l'union
bancaire c'est la solution aux problèmes
de la zone euro
nous ne voulons plus que les
contribuables père les banques doivent
payer pour les boucs
l'union bancaire c'est comme une fusée à
trois étages niveau 1 un gendarme
européen unique surveillera directement
les banques en lieu et place des
autorités nationales de tutelle niveau 2
un système de garantie des dépôts sera
mis en place
autrement dit si une banque fait
faillite ses clients récupéreront leurs
avoirs à hauteur de cent mille euros
niveau 3 le régulateur européen
disposera de super pouvoirs pour régler
les crises bancaires par exemple ordonné
une cession ou une fermeture d'activités
bref l'union bancaire c'est le big
brother de la banque alors l'union
fait-elle vraiment la force
alors lui on bancaire à c'est ce dont on
discute à bruxelles et dans les
capitales européennes actuellement nous
sommes avec jean paul gauzès bonjour
bonjour vous êtes député européen
français vous êtes membre de la
commission des affaires économiques et
financières
ici au parlement l'union bancaire en
quelques mots ça serait quoi qu'est ce
que ça changerait ça changerait si elle
était mise en place
ça changerait le fait que au lieu
d'avoir une control morcelé des banques
une responsabilité nationale on ne
pourrait avoir une responsabilité au
niveau européen la fois comme le dit
votre reportage en termes de supervision
en termes de garantie des dépôts
mais vous allez dire que derrière les
mots il faut chercher les réalités et
aujourd'hui on est en train de modifier
ou d'envisager de modifier un système
qui a été mis en place en 2010 sur la
supervision bancaire et à ce moment là
le parlement voulait l'union bancaire
voulais qu'il y ait des autorités
européennes supranationale qui
contrôlent voulait qu'une garantie des
dépôts via un fonds en cas de crise
bancaire
à l'époque les états n'ont pas voulu et
maintenant aujourd'hui ils ont trouvé la
martingale
voilà mes mais juste deux petites
questions là-dessus la garantie des
dépôts elles existent il ya des gens qui
vont dire sur la garantie des dépôts
elles existent d'abord en force elles
existent il ya déjà une supervision il
ya déjà été clair il ya actuellement un
texte en préparation sur la garantie
dépôt avait des difficultés pour le
mettre au point patia des discordances
entre les pays et les volontés les pays
quant à supervision il existe bien une
autorité de supervision européenne
le bea mai
dont les états membres ont voulu que les
pouvoirs sont très limitées et dont les
responsables ont été choisis de telle
sorte qu'il puisse pas faire d'ombré aux
régulateurs nationaux
aujourd'hui on fait on propose de faire
ce que nous nous avions proposé il ya
deux ans et si cette union bancaire
venait à voir le jour
est-ce que ça serait vraiment une
solution à la crise je pense que au
niveau des banques qui sont aujourd'hui
des banques transfrontalières les
grandes banques où il ya des risques
et oui il faut des contrôles des
supervisions intelligente ce dispositif
est de nature à réduire le risque et à
mieux le prévenir
éventuellement et les dispositifs
d'accompagnement permettrait de ne pas
faire peser sur contribuables mais quand
on voit l'interview de michel barnier
c'est à propos de son fonds de
résolution des crises bancaires dont le
texte est aujourd'hui en discussion
donc les livres les pierres pour faire
cet édifice est existe il s'agit
maintenant de vouloir les ajuster juste
pour comprendre par exemple on sépare
donc il ya une banque en espagne qui
s'appelle banquiers à qui est en
difficulté
donc je dis je prends un exemple comme
ça si banquiers à l'avenir après l'union
bancaire était en difficulté
ça veut dire que la société générale ou
le crédit agricole pourrait voler au
secours de banques à nous c'est pas ça
du tout ça veut dire d'abord que
s'impliquera pas bancaire puisque le
temps que les textes se passe premier
moment de cas je l'espère en tout cas
soit réglé mais ça voudrait dire que
premièrement banquier aurait été
surveillés peut-être plus attentivement
qu'elle ne l'a été par les régulateurs
nationaux que les pères la perspective
européenne des prises ça voudrait dire
aussi que les aides pour éventuellement
recapitaliser bankia ou permettre à
manquer de faire face à ses obligations
auraient pu être puiser dans un fonds
de garantie est pas dans la cotivo opère
et non pas dans la pièce des états est
ce qu'on y va vers cette union bancaire
est ce que vous êtes optimiste je suis
modérément optimiste je pense que c'est
nécessaire de le faire
je crains que la volonté politique ne
soit pas là et surtout je regrette c'est
que l'europe soit toujours au plus haut
mieux réactives et proactives si nous
avions pris en cl les chefs d'état et de
gouvernement avaient suivi l'orientation
du parlement en 2010 aujourd'hui l'union
bancaire serait pratiquement fait est en
tout cas elle aurait pu déjà fonctionné
or nous traitons les problèmes une fois
qu'il se pose faut-il construire un
hôpital avant que les gens soient
malades ou est ce que parce qu'on
construit un hôpital les gens deviennent
malades
je crois que c'est là le problème
aujourd'hui majeurs de l'europe
est ce que vous croyez c'est le grand
débat actuellement est ce que vous
pensez qu'on va aller vers ce saut
fédéral que même les marchés par exemple
appellent de leurs voeux
je crois que les observateurs attentifs
voit bien que avec la globalisation la
mondialisation et surtout non loin de la
finance la taille nationale est trop
petit qu' il faut une plus d'europe
mieux d'europe ça veut dire des abandons
de souveraineté
ça ne veut pas dire la création
d'etats-unis d'europe ça veut dire
simplement admettre que dans certains
domaines où une coordination est
nécessaire ou un substrat financiers
nécessaires il faut plus d'europe sous
une forme fédérale
est-ce que les opinions publiques qui
sont prêtes je ne le crois pas est ce
que les chefs d'état et de gouvernement
sont prêts à faire cette espèce de
révolution culturelle
j'aimerais que ce soit possible merci
jean paul gauzès d'avoir accepté notre
invitation plus d'europe c'est ce que
vous avez dit on va en parler dans un
instant avec notre confrère jean
quatremer quelques correspondants ici du
journal libération je vous propose de
regarder tout d'abord ce qu'on dise les
télévisions du monde les télévisions
européennes mais également je vous
propose de regarder ce que dit sur cette
europe fédérale parti clairement la
télévision taïwanaise regarder
le sauvetage de l'euro doit intervenir
en moins de trois mois c'est ce qu'a
déclaré mardi christine lagarde la
directrice générale du fonds monétaire
international au cours d'un entretien
avec une télévision américaine
d'information continue la zone euro est
une union monétaire
mais il n'y a pas d'union politique ni
d'union fiscale alors les allemands sont
fatigués de payer pour les quatre petits
cochons portugais grecs italiens et
espagnols
ils savent qu'ils ne rembourseront
jamais leur dette
la part des états unis d'europe c'était
le kit comme je disais tout à l'heure
d'un livre que vous avez écrit en 2007
les états unis d'europe
vous pensez que vous verrez ça de de
votre vivant votre vivant politique on
veut dire en fait sur la crise de la
zone euro angela merkel a répété que la
consolidation budgétaire et la
croissance sont les deux faces d'une
même médaille
elle reconnaît que l'europe à deux
vitesses est déjà une réalité
certains pays sont en mesure de faire
l'union fiscale d'autres en seront
exclues comme la grande bretagne et le
danemark
alors comme chaque semaine dans cette
émission nous recevons un correspondant
ici à bruxelles aujourd'hui c'est jean
quatremer bonjour bonjour c est le
correspondant ici du journal libération
l'europe fédérale on a envie de dire
l'europe l'europe il ya de gaulle qui
disait ça il ya quelques années l'europe
fédérale est ce que c'est que quelque
chose qui va pouvoir se produire
ce sont là faut dire les choses très
clairement on n'a plus le choix elle
sait où le grand saut vers l'europe
fédérale où le gros saut dans le vide
mais les demi-mesures le moyen terme
ce qu'on fait en fait depuis trois ans
pour essayer de régler la crise de la
zone euro ne fonctionne pas alors
pourquoi parce que tout simplement les
marchés depuis 20 ans n'ont jamais cru
au projet euro
de monnaie unique parce que pour une
monnaie sans état ça n'est pas possible
il faut un état qui prennent des
décisions qui exerce la gouvernance
budgétaire et économie pendant dix ans
ça a fonctionné tant bien que mal et la
crise de 2008 donc la crise des
subprimes la crise de l'endettement
public à montrer qu'effectivement il n'y
avait personne pour obliger un état
respecté sa parole pour redistribuer
entre les pays riches et les pays
pauvres
bref n'avait pas de budget fédéral break
que l'union européenne en réalité
n'existait pas donc ils veulent un état
il c'est pour ça qu'ils poussent les
états membres à faire ce saut fédéral
nous laissera donc l'explosion c'est un
constat assez assez partagés
effectivement qu'il faut une europe qui
soit plus fédérale mais est ce que c'est
possible d'y arriver est ce que par
exemple tout simplement les chefs d'état
qui se réunissent très régulièrement ils
sûrs un sommet à bruxelles ce qui est ce
qu'ils vont accepter est ce que françois
hollande va accepter de perdre une
partie de la souveraineté de la france
pour la laisser ici à bruxelles
il a le choix il peut être le
l'équivalent du général de gaulle pour
l'union européenne où l'équivalent de
paul reynaud
le premier ministre français qui a remis
les pleins pouvoirs au maréchal pétain
voilà c'est à peu près ça sera l'homme
qui aura détruit l'euro est sans doute
l'union européenne où l'homme qu'il aura
sauvé donc pour moi la question ne se
pose pas aux terres de l'est ce que je
vais accepter de donner un peu de ma
fille de mme souveraineté à l'union
européenne un peu partagé ils n'ont pas
le choix
angela merkel non plus parce qu angela
merkel ne pourra pas laisser son nom
comme étant la chancelière qui a détruit
l'europe elle apparaîtra faisait c'est
pas moi qu'il l'ait dit la comparaison a
été faite par l'ancien ministre des
affaires étrangères allemand joschka
fischer qui a dit qu'actuellement la
politique d'angela merkel était
dramatique pour l'europe et qu'elle
risquait d'être de laisser son nom dans
l'histoire comme étant la chancelière
qui avait détruit l'europe tout comme
hitler avait détruit l'europe avant elle
vous imaginez la dureté de la
comparaison finalement qu'il a fait
qu'est ce qu'il ya de scandaleux à dire
comme elle le fait par exemple moi
j'accepterai éventuellement de payer
pour les erreurs des voisins si je peux
d'abord en amont contrôler ce qu'ils
font à mâcher à la raison mais la raison
100% se dire que actuelle les français
rêvent d'une chose ce serait d'avoir le
code de la carte visa des allemands pour
pouvoir dépenser librement et les
allemands disent non on veut bien vous
donner le code mais dans ce cas là on va
regarder ce que vous allez dépenser
qu'est-ce que qu'est ce que vous achetez
quelles sont vos priorités etc
moi je pense que les allemands dans
cette affaire ont raison c'est à dire
qu' on ne peut pas avoir d'union
budgétaire d'union fiscale a partagé des
pensées des dettes publiques sans
contrôle politique et surtout sans
démocratisation parce que encore une
fois les français quand il entend le mot
fédération ils entendent espèce de super
état qui va tout contrôlé à bruxelles ce
n'est pas de ça dont il s'agit
il s'agit de répartir les compétences
entre les différents états membres et le
centre donc bruxelles et d'instaurer la
démocratie parce qu'actuellement il faut
bien voir que tel que fonctionne l'union
européenne elle n'est pas démocratique
on la donne est de plus en plus de
pouvoirs à la commission européenne
depuis trois ans mais sans aucun
contrôle du parlement européen sur la
commission ou du parlement européen sur
le conseil des ministres de même les
parlement nationaux n'ont absolument
aucun contrôle sur le conseil des
ministres parce qu'ils contrôlent un 25e
du conseil des ministres où un 17e pour
la zone euro donc il ya un vrai problème
de démocratie les allemands disent on
peut pas continuer comme ça donc je
pense que dans cette affaire l'allemagne
a raison c'est pour ça qu'ils disent
pour que l'europe soit plus démocratique
il faudrait éventuellement une élection
au suffrage universel alors de qui du
président du conseil du président de la
commission ça serait le même
oui alors l'idée ce serait de peut-être
de fusionner les postes parce qu'il ya
trop de président en europe plaisir ça
devient il le rappeler loisirs où c'est
le rôle des présidents et pourquoi pas
l'amicale des de la pétanque etc
ça devient du délire
donc ils ont raison il faut fusionner
les postes et c'est plutôt gentil de
leur part parce que ils sont pas pour
l'élection en réalité pour l'élection du
président de la commission de la prison
de l'europe suffrage universel parce que
c'est pas leurs traditions ils sont
plutôt parlementariste ils veulent faire
plaisir aux français il va voilà on va
vous donner un super président de la
république européenne
en réalité ce qui risque de se passer
c'est plutôt que le parlement européen
on donnera le pouvoir au parlement
européen d'élire directement le
président de la commission et les
membres de la commission c'est à dire
que la commission correspondra à une
majorité au parlement politique on
marche séparément on entend aujourd'hui
les commissaires européens sont choisis
par par les gouvernements alors certes
il passe ensuite devant le devant le
parlement
derrière les halles démocratie formelle
en réalité est ce que vous pensez que
ont parlé de cette europe fédérale est
ce que vous pensez que les peuples
d'europe
quand on voit quand même l'impopularité
de bruxelles en france mais dans
d'autres pays d'europe également ce que
vous pensez que les peuples européens
sont prêts à accepter de donner encore
une fois de la souveraineté ici à
bruxelles
c'est un curieux parce que on les médias
ou les hommes politiques parlent de
l'impopularité de l'europe et essaie à
chaque fois curieux parce que d'abord
les citoyens ne votent pas pour des
partis anti européens dont la plupart
des pays je veux dire que par tous et
les majorités pro européenne et son
gouvernement et les sondages montrent
que les gens sont trop repères ils
veulent garder l'euro par exemple en
france à 75% le en allemagne même le
nombre de d'allemands favorable la
monnaie unique ne fait que croître en
dépit de la crise
donc il ya en fait je pense qu'à un vrai
sentiment européen si on dit aux gens
voilà vous avez le choix entre le retour
à l'état nation ou une vraie intégration
devrait fédération que vous pourrez
contrôler démocratiquement
il faut leur poser la question je pense
qu'ils répondront oui mais on
n'échappera pas à des référendums à
travers toute l'europe pour demander aux
gens est ce que vous êtes prêts à faire
ce sous et si les gens disent non il
faudra respecter leur décision et on
reviendra au bon vieux état nation à
l'équilibré des forces au sein de
l'europe on aura toujours du travail où
les journalistes quand même que vous le
sachiez ce que vous nous dites donc
c'est il faut redonner ou en tout cas
donner la parole au peuple
là on n'a pas le choix merci beaucoup
jean quatremer d'avoir accepté notre
invitation va maintenant parler d'un
autre sujet le bisphénol à vous savez
c'était cette substance qui se
trouvaient dans les biberons et qui
maintenant est interdite alors nous
allons savoir ce que l'europe a fait
contre le bisphénol a c'est une enquête
qui est signée démenti mme malgorn et
ensuite on retrouve
kathia gilder et son invité nous sommes
dans la campagne belge à quelques
kilomètres de liège
elise a accepté de nous ouvrir les
placards de sa cuisine toute la
vaisselle est en verre ou en inox y
compris le biberon du bébé et si cette
petite fille est en pleine forme
sa jeune maman elle a eu dès la
naissance de graves problèmes de santé
je suis né avec une mamie knock une
mammite c'est avec lesquels la poitrine
du nez qui sort la poitrine cc c'est un
peu choquant mais là déjà il y avait un
trop plein d'hormones il y avait un
déséquilibre et c'est vrai que ma maman
avait beaucoup de produits en plastique
qui gênait beaucoup là-dedans a conservé
aussi beaucoup là-dedans et
immanquablement je me dis on a été
contaminé alors pour ne pas reproduire
les erreurs de sa mère élise s'est
débarrassée de tous les objets en
plastique susceptibles de contenir des
aliments
à partir du moment où j'ai supprimé tout
ça est bien ma santé s'est améliorée car
élise a subi il ya dix ans de graves
dérèglements hormonaux au niveau de sa
thyroïde
si aujourd'hui elle est guérie la jeune
femme est convaincue d'être rescapés de
cette molécule
le bisphénol a qui sert à fabriquer des
objets en plastique et qui peut
contaminer les aliments et être
ingurgitées même si élise pense avoir
été intoxiqués rien n'est prouvé
si l'arrêt de l'utilisation de matières
plastiques et procure ce sentiment de
guérison devient j'en suis très heureux
c'est vraiment quelque chose
tant mieux pour elle maintenant je peux
leur a su la rassurer ou rassurer ses
proches qui continuent à utiliser des
matières plastiques n'y a aucun danger
pour la santé humaine
car pour ce porte parole du syndicat du
plastique
il s'agit plus d'une impression que
d'une réalité si on trouve du bisphénol
a dans les claviers d'ordinateurs dans
les lunettes ou dans cette cloche à
fromage la molécule serait quasiment
absente de ces contenants alimentaires
les emballages qui sont là d'un village
de la vie courante vous nous trouvez
nulle pas de bisphénol a ni en matière
première nil ce sont des matières
plastiques qui n'utilisent pas le
bisphénol-a en contact en fabrication
alors fini le bisphénol a dans les
emballages plastiques
pas si sûr en tout cas pas pour katia
consommatrices averti qu'ils arrivent à
en déceler comme dans cette bouteille de
lait donc la numéro 7 les polycarbonates
avec dpa alors que c'est un lait bio
c'est un petit quelque chose qui
m'énerve qui m'agace donc je me suis dit
je vais en parler sur le blog
cette militante de la première heure a
décidé d'avertir le public sur ce
qu'elle considère être un véritable
risque pour la santé
sur son blog elle informe sur les
dangers du bisphénol a de simple
consommatrice à la même montée sa
boutique à narbonne où elles vont une
gamme de contenants alimentaires sans
perturbateurs endocriniens
alors ça y est voilà c'est pour emballer
les sandwichs ou les crêpes roulées
c'est du plastique mais sans bpa sans
phtalates sont intéressés c'est du
plastique numéro 4
et ce n'est pas anecdotique pour katia
le bisphénol-a n'est pas sans danger
c'est pierre comme poison c'est
carrément quelque chose qui est calé
dans votre corps et qui va aller
ailleurs
maintenant on va à synthétiser peu de
cellules de la glande mammaire du
politique et où un rapide de pâtes rémy
ou au contraire on à réduire la
production de spermatozoïdes
donc c'est vraiment dangereux puisque sa
valeur
le système hormonal de l'industriel ou
du consommateur averti
qui a raison la réalité scientifique est
encore difficile à établir à toulouse
les chercheurs de l'inra ont de
multiples expérimentations sur des
animaux
ils ont mis à jour des relations de
cause à effet mais pour l'heure aucune
certitude sur l'impact du bisphénol a
sur l'homme il ya de fortes suspicions à
partir des preuves apportées chez
l'animal toute la question reste posée
définitivement pour la transposition
alors pour regard de nombreuses études
scientifiques publiées un peu partout
dans le monde
l'union européenne a choisi d'appliquer
le principe de précaution pour les
biberons au grand dam des industriels
il ya eu cette décision européenne
d'interdire les biberons fabriqués à
partir de polycarbonate
mais cette décision n'est absolument pas
fondées sur des études scientifiques qui
le démontre encore une fois l'agent
sanitaire européenne avait dit qu'il n'y
avait pas de danger et le dis toujours
il n'y a pas de danger à utiliser des
biberons en polycarbonate
mais pour katia qui a déjà déclaré la
guerre aux plastiques et l'interdiction
qui touche les biberons n'est pas
suffisante pour elle il faudrait élargir
la liste des objets nocif à proscrire
un combat qui fait de plus en plus
d'émules en france mais aussi au delà
nos frontières notamment dans le nord de
l'europe
reportage chili et clémentine maligorne
avec denis iacono nous sommes avec
corinne lepage bonjour bonjour merci
d'être avec nous pour parler de ce sujet
très sensible du bisphénol-a vous êtes
députée européenne élue assidus ici et
membre de la commission de
l'environnement de là santé publique et
de la sécurité alimentaire
alors je vous ai vu beaucoup réagir
pendant ce reportage finalement on
entend de son de cloche les uns nous
disent mais non on n'y a pas de risque
et les autres nous disent ici regarder
quels sont les effets sur la santé
qui croire qui a raison pour moi je
dirais que je suis absolument convaincu
des effets du bisphénol a l'ansès en
france qui est notre agence sanitaire à
nous reconnu qu'il y avait de plus que
de très fortes probabilités plus que ça
une étude américaine très récentes
mettent en lumière le fait que ce
produit serait reprotoxiques c'est à
dire que sur quatre générations
on va retrouver des effets du bisphénol
a par voie de conséquence je me réjouis
que la france les proscrits dans les
biberons
je me réjouis que la commission les
faits sur notre insistance et malgré
l'attitude absolument incompréhensible
de l'efs ça mais je reviendrai sur ce
point tout à l'heure et je pense que ça
doit être étendu de manière globale à
tous les produits alimentaires
vous dites qu'en l'absence de certitude
scientifique enfin on a quand même 95%
des études sont croissants portage qui
nous dit qu'il faut appliquer le
principe de précaution est premièrement
oui bien sûr mais deuxièmement en
réalité il faut bien voir qu'aujourd'hui
malheureusement dans la plupart des cas
on n'applique pas le principe de
précaution le principe de précaution il
joue aujourd'hui souvent malheureusement
en faveur de l'industrie en défaveur de
la santé publique qu'il faut être quand
même très claires et plus on parle du
principe de précaution souvent c'est
moins olympique pour le bisphénol a on
peut pas faire autrement j'allais dire
parce que toutes les études sont
aujourd'hui à peu près concordantes et
tout le monde est à peu près d'accord en
ce qui concerne le bisphénol a mais il
ya bien d'autres produits notamment des
perturbateurs endocriniens sur lequel il
y a aujourd'hui beaucoup de débats vous
savez les phtalates par exemple les
phtalates par exemple formaldéhyde
un certain nombre d'autres d'autres
produits vous savez il y à ce que l'on
appelle les semeurs de doute les
marchands de doute c'est à dire que les
grands lobbys industriels ont mis en
place un système qui est extrêmement
efficace qui consiste à trouver un
certain nombre de scientifiques qui font
des études pour dire qu'on n'est pas sûr
que et alors que le on n'est pas sûr que
devrait conduire au principe de
précaution le on n'est pas sûr que
conduit exactement à la verse et c'est
contre cela qu'il faut se battre parce
que faut bien comprendre que la santé
publique
c'est d'abord un enjeu qui nous
intéresse tous mais au-delà de ça ça a
un coût énorme pour la collectivité
lorsque nous sommes malades les uns et
les autres et nous arrivons à un stade
où notamment ce qui concerne le
perturbateur endocrinien nous avons des
problèmes qui touchent à l'espèce
lorsque nous avons perdu 50 % de la
fertilité humaine
en l'espace d'un demi siècle il ya
peut-être une question à se poser vous
lancer une alerte aujourd'hui très
clairement où dit c'est très dangereux
il faut il comprendre pas déçu très
dangereux je dis nous sommes en face
d'un certain nombre de produits qu'on
appelle les perturbateurs endocriniens
je suis rapporteur fictif sur un texte
qui va venir sur ce sujet dont nous
avons toutes les raisons de penser
qu'ils ont des impacts extrêmement
lourde sur la santé humaine et sur la
fertilité humaine et par voie de
conséquence il est plus qu urgent non
seulement de fait toutes les recherches
nécessaires mais dans la tente de
prendre toutes les mesures de précaution
nécessaires alors sur la question des
responsabilités on a rencontré lors de
ce reportage le président de
l'association réseau environnement santé
qui alerte sur le bisphénol-a je vous
propose d'écouter la question qu'il a
apposée à la représentant des citoyens
européenne que vous êtes écouter
pourquoi vous attendez pourquoi vous ne
prenez pas vos responsabilités pour
mettre fin à ce scandale de l' agence
européenne de l'afssa qui continue
d'expliquer qu'il n'y a aucun problème
avec le bisphénol qui continuent de
reprendre mot pour mot les arguments de
l'industrie des plastiques
alors que l'évidence scientifique et la
95% la littérature scientifique le dit
il voit là une substance qui impacte la
santé enfants mais des adultes des mêmes
de sur plusieurs générations
alors corinne lepage répondez lui la
raison de mettre en cause la jambe alors
je le répète je serai simplement andré
cicolella que je ne les ai pas attendu
avec un certain nombre d'autres puisque
moi depuis deux ans et demi où je suis
députée européenne je mène une véritable
croisade non pas contre lève ça parce
que nous avons besoin d'une agence des
expertises mais contre les conflits
d'intérêts et les dysfonctionnements de
l'aef ça et cette année c'est très
important le parlement européen a refusé
le quitus à l'efs ça c'est à dire ne lui
a pas donné quitus de ses comptes
précisément à cause des conflits
d'intérêts que nous estimons absolument
inacceptable dit conflits d'intérêts
vous dit elle et cette agence ne rend
pas service jeudi indépendance
exactement je dis que nous avons insisté
un certain nombre de cas de figure
absolument inacceptable a commencé par
madame banati qu'était présidente du
conseil d'administration que l'efsa
continue à accepter dans ces panels
d'experts des experts qui appartiennent
à lille si lille s'y étant un organisme
qui regroupe tout le lobby de
l'agroalimentaire et que la permanence
de ces conflits d'intérêts a bien
entendu une incidence sur les
évaluations sur les méthodes
d'évaluation sur ce que l'on recherche
c'est que l'on ne recherchait pas
enclave où dit que l'efsa l'agencé
européenne de sécurité des aliments et
or est au service des lobbys ne rend pas
sans les images
j'emploierai pas des mots de manière
aussi cru mais
il est tout à fait pas respecter sa
mission je lui reste zen est marrante de
ne pas remplir sa mission de ne pas nous
mettra même nous mêmes décideurs publics
parlementaire et exécutif d'avoir une
véritable information fiable dont nous
avons impérativement besoin
je reproche à l'efsa de refuser de
respecter les demandes qui lui ont été
faites par l'exécutif comme par les
parlementaires de changer ses méthodes
de fonctionnement
il ya des légers progrès qui sont faits
c'est notoirement insuffisant ce qui
fait qu alors que nous avons besoin de
plus en plus d' expertise indépendante
nous en avons moins en moins est ce que
le parlement européen qui représente
quand même les citoyens a les moyens de
faire quelque chose change ça c'est les
moyens que nous avons ils sont modestes
vous savez c'est le guide du son la
refuser et j'espère que cette année nous
voterons ce que j'avais proposé l'année
dernière c'est-à-dire une mise en
réserve de 5% du budget de l'efsa c'est
à dire que mon blog 5% de son budget
jusqu'à ce qu'elle change ses méthodes
de fonctionnement
voilà c'est les outils que nous avons
pour montrer que nous sommes en profond
désaccord avec la manière dont les
choses se font sur le bisphénol a comme
sur l'aspartame comme sur les ogm comme
sont une autre série de sujets ça
pourrait être votée bientôt ben on en
reparlera à la rentrée oui bien sûr et
là on se reverra sans doute d'ici à la
rentrée merci beaucoup corinne lepage
l'allemand était avec nous dans europe
hebdo on se retrouve pour la dernière
fois à strasbourg très bonne suite de
programmes sur les chaînes
parlementaires